what are you hoping to find Nina hoping
to find nothing good news and eat
because we haven't eaten enough on our
Dallas trip right yeah
chivalry it's not dead it's not dead so
happy it is our last day in Dallas and
then we head back to Toronto tonight
[Music]
okay so it's our last day and one of the
things I love doing when I do Airbnb is
clean up the place as if it was my own
like I want looking nicer than when I
got here and so that means everything
cleaning out tidying up look lining up
the chairs doing all of the dishes right
empty sink making the beds right look at
that
making the bed everything super crisp
super clean only minor things are like
don't know what to do with like a wine
bottle right don't know what to do with
the wine bottle put that it's a couple
minor minor tiny little touches but you
know this is somebody's business and
it's not returned you know it's not some
big giant married hotel corporation it's
an entrepreneur and I know entrepreneurs
who do air babies have nightmare
scenarios people come in trash the place
steal stuff that come in as a disaster I
know it's always a concern every time
that you bring somebody on to stay at
your place and so I want to be the
opposite I want to be I want to as a
disaster scenario like tear the place
apart I want to be like the best case
scenario I want to be that the so good
case scenario that's never happened to
you before that's the scenario I want to
be and I just think it's right I think
it's good I think it's good you know
it's just the love for entrepreneurs
anyway so we're almost done packing up
cleaning up and then we're going to
explore a little more Dallas and then
you
[Music]
all right we checked out Nina got us
some coffee
where's the coffee not just regular
coffee our go-to in Dallas right now the
what Palmieri
palmeri's cappuccino we got pump minute
oh this is mine oh yeah shake it mom hmm
oh it's good all right we're gonna go
ahead to some breakfast
Norma's Cafe which we missed on day one
and eat because we haven't eaten enough
on our Dallas trip right yeah yeah Nina
wants to eat some more yeah lots of meat
maybe maybe some more brisket let's go
it always rains in our vacation even
when it's not supposed to rain we're
we're grateful it came on the last day
though we're gonna be spending most of
the day inside yeah breakfast all day at
Norma's cafe since 1956 look at that all
right Nina go get some breakfast let's
hope Norma's is just as good so we
stand in line and wheat our table or we
sit at the bar every day of the week
every day of the week
let's go let's go starting off with some
fried pickles
your fingers okay go eat it hot that's
it
this is hot really fancy cafe kites up
good to the last squeeze all right I
like it a lot right Nina
Wow that's gigantic although there's a
lot of stuff on top of the green chicken
chicken chicken
how's it feel your first greens of the
trip really good all right here's mine
all right there we go look at that
that's manageable I just had that that's
not hot giant you have to do that this
is fine
pick it image give a small hand uh try
the coconut pie
all right I like it winner oh man I am
full
how you doing it just hit the side of it
look what's more important filming
content for believe nation or not
getting hit by chucks okay it's obvious
we need contact guys content wait that
is a point there she has a point
guys always close the door for your wife
girlfriend
chivalry it's not dead it's not dead
okay next up we're gonna hit up a pretty
famous mall cuz it's raining it's gonna
be indoors last stop before heading to
the airport
[Music]
all right we made it to where are we I
want to say Highland farms but that's
not his Island barns is a grocery store
in Toronto we're at the Highland
something mall it's actually outdoors
which is not great for the rain I
thought it was an indoor thing it's an
outdoor mall we've got two hours of
browsing and shopping to do and then
head to the airport what are you hoping
to find Nina you're hoping to find
nothing yeah good news when I want to
find something never find it so rather
nothing but well that's great that means
you hit your goal so you're happy have
no expectations and it's easy to be
surprised and delighted perfect it's
already a winning chip for Nina we
haven't even left the parking lot
it's raining it's raining
Nina's running running run it wouldn't
be a comical vacation without rain
that's how we roll
it's gotta rain okay so so kind of
Starbucks because you know we haven't
had enough coffee yet today right might
as well have another coffee sit inside
enjoy the rain aim each other's company
there's soaked how did that happen
[Music]
just ran into a fan of the channel this
is Chad from Dallas what's your favorite
video on the channel people I love the
current Grant Cardone videos anything
inspirational for sales and motivation
those are the ones to watch my came over
to say hi because look look he's got the
he's got the 10x rule sitting on the
desk said I got to say hi to this guy we
just had to quick the M - grant - all
right oh yeah hustle make some money be
successful
[Music]
the rain has started again we're gonna
take off in this place what's about to
happen Nina you're gonna go get the car
wait for you
Nina's gonna stand out of this nice
awning here and I'm gonna go run get the
car right that's am I gonna go to the
bouquet ready selfie the background all
right here we go
it's okay good husband material get rain
on my face that's how we do it
chivalry is not dead 20:18 make yourself
proud that's it
I made it I'm drenched look you're that
look at that look at the rain okay let's
go get Nina I can't press the stop
button because their fingers it to what
and start recognizing stop stop
recording dry dry dry stop no still not
working how do you stop it when your
fingers are too way here we go this is
it this is the winner
hello such a wise remove it alright
let's go to the employ
[Music]
so Nina what do we just find out our
flight is delayed our flight is delayed
I liked it I liked the resourcefulness
but it's raining and our flight is
delayed it feels like you can't have a
quality trip without that happening
right of course it's a caracal trip yeah
here let's see let's see if we can have
an early one I don't know how many
direct flights are though from Dallas
with Toronto we made it through security
Nina didn't get stopped
you should get stopped or something no
stopping today I'll look to have a
little video game section here
you don't play some video games that's
cool this is big this is cool I like it
we are also here very early like what
three hours yeah three hours early and
our flight is delayed Wow
so we're gonna see if we can find the
earlier flight or get some work done
because we got four hours it's the best
the parts of 220 satis 200 208 yeah it's
probably over so we got four hours to
wait just missed I guess I think that's
the plane that Air Canada line this
about to leave just missed it early
flight okay settle in get some food get
to work
I've been some crazy work some some what
I was doing last night the one in the
morning just exploded and an awesome
this is coming I guess by the time by
the time calling by the time this is
that like the work will have already
been watched but it's look at how
special the wife is she went and got me
oh this is the new this is a new
Starbucks protein drink yeah what is it
Hellman we don't have this in Canada for
me to know we're here look how cute you
okay wow that is nasty
first of all I got shocked when I put my
tongue on it but holy cow for a
Starbucks drink that is nasty
where's the almond in here this is
brutal okay wow thank you
look at that that's yeah same thing okay
okay I got to finish my work - I love
and periods of productivity
really
when you get 45 minutes and you're just
in the zone fast right it's the best
it's the best okay I mean I'm eat and
eat Nina it's 5:40 the paper support off
with the late to play was supposed to
live at 5:00 to 10:00 yeah it extended
the sixth head it's 5:40 plane isn't
here yet I was feeling about this
hey I got him here perfectly on time
maybe we shouldn't be traveling together
if that's it that's a message I'll go
for business class you can go back
economy what do you think it's 5:55 the
plane has arrived really for 6:20 that's
not bad ten minute extra delay Nina's
hustling there's some believe nation
magic reaching out to the community
planning some kind of stuff but plane
has arrived looks like you're gonna get
on I made it
what are your hopes for this flight
no no fast normal speed okay get home
get home get the car go see the dogs
do you want you say that gonna freak out
at the toilet in time for some movie
selections like watching an action movie
public red sparrow Nina's watching
cartoons good
Ferdinand's
[Music]
this one's off the plane yeah yeah man
they open the door the guy header he
didn't when it goes like all right I'm
having I'm Matt take listen
opportunities come your way what do you
do you take them okay that's what we do
that's what entrepreneurs do that's the
chemicals do that's how we roll
hey customs home that's the plan
and enough friends internet that's how
we do two questions
where you in from Dallas Texas what you
there for vacation thank you that's
right
that's right okay let's get the wife to
the washroom and then home to the dock
[Music]
when you have a choice between speed and
convenience speed speed
I'll take the stairs everyday over the
escalators if it's faster stairs every
day of the escalators of is faster
see now you go and move in sidewalk
because there's nobody in front of you
see that's normal walking pace and then
the moving sidewalk goodbye goodbye
speed over convenience always speed over
convenience but if you get the option to
do both speed and convenience always
take that or you end up back there
we love you Nina I'm taking the stairs
speed over convenience speed over
convenience like I'm early at 6:00 look
at this where is she Nina it's one floor
it's one floor Nina it's one floor how
you doing Nina sweating you ready to go
home she gonna shower all right
I need to go home and and take the dogs
out Wow all right I'll do that no
problem and then I need to work I got
some messages that I need to send out
that I couldn't do for my laptop that
have to go tonight tonight tonight I
know I go to sleep
and hug this one oh there we go yeah hug
this one night just to see myself here
you go to bed and hug myself listen
that's not that bad strategy okay
self-love is important I see the car
get your keys ready unlike that trunk
one of the great things of having a red
car is that not many people have it so
it's always easy to find in the parking
lot what's all this junk in here looks
like junk guys close the door for you
ladies the gentlemen are you trying to
make it not Smurf smokes for me aren't
you but it's still oh my gosh how can a
human being fit in here like I lost
circulation to my leg look at this press
one huh okay
oh oh that's like Chinese water torture
you know one chip at a time
you
you
we made it we made it best part of the
trip Nina why you Taemin how'd you pay
David on the street in the hot page
walking down the street on the hot day
the day that you you were sweating and
face off and complaining a lot it's a
second highlight bar well like I'm glad
all of that work I did preparing amazing
food places to go to none of them made
the highlight for me man hot weather
sauna and she's happy that's the lesson
that's a highway probably this speech
the keynote from what from when you're
here you seen you was great seeing you
picking you up at the airport I was a
highlight on your kind of sweaty second
your miracle was a highlight I think is
spending I like seeing the plants from
the action I'm playing all these
surprises for Nina they don't always go
well there's a decent hit rate this time
but I just like seeing the the planes
that I have come alive in action so yeah
now let's get the dogs
[Music]
okay we're gonna end up there
thank you guys for joining us on our
journey if you want to know why we did
this in the first place and watch the
first video in this series so check it
out next to me I think you're gonna
enjoy it continue to believe and we'll
see you there